she has often heard about a third
approach called post biotics that's skin
care Market targets how is this approach
different from the other two
um okay so what is prebiotics prebiotics
is
uh when basically bacteria are given
something some let's say food with some
conditions to produce desired molecules
desired metabolites probiotics we
understand that's when a live bacteria
or usually actually not live bacteria
but some bits and pieces of you know
good bacteria
um
are used and post-biotics is when it's
actually the easiest approach in easiest
from the point of view of applications
because the good bacteria is grown in a
lab
and then the products of this bacteria
the post-biotic the results of their
activity a metabolite anti-inflammatory
molecule whatever it is it's this
product that is used and applied uh
let's say in a skincare products
or all right that was
um quite helpful uh do we have any other
questions if yes please put in the chat
and I have a general question that I
would like to ask so when we look at
different data sets we find some data
very specific to a specific condition
where we don't have the control samples
in the data set right but uh can this
thing be done that if we have a data set
let's say for a condition and we have a
control
uh sample set from a different data set
and then we would like to compare it is
that possible because we were discussing
this that it is not actually that the
microbiome stays constant like is there
a normal microbiome tool which we can
compare any data set
great questions yes
so
I don't think that you know we have this
kind of standard healthy microbiome
reference data set like we have in uh
let's say uh human genetics where there
are some reference human genomes and yes
there are certain problems with them and
so on but nevertheless these are the
reference data sets that everybody is
sort of
um comparing their dataways right
we don't have that in microbiome we
don't have it yet okay I'm sure we will
have it you know soon however having
said that I am sure we can use the
controls from other studies
because uh
I mean okay we can use the the reference
data sets so controls from other studies
provided
you know they're the same with age and
various other factors so there are many
factors that we need to take into
consideration pollution if these people
live in big cities
um you know what's what is their
Lifestyles and so on but overall
I think age and gender obviously are the
ethnicity as well actually but this is
not really known whether the ethnicity
is is a factor or whether you know let's
say Japanese microbiomes differ from you
know Western European
uh samples because of lifestyle or
because of ethnicity we don't know that
yet but because the general conclusions
are the same
so yes the short answer we can use
controls from other studies provided we
check for age gender and ethnicity
uh does it answer a question or do they
need something okay so there was a
question here does skin microbiome
change
it's a very deep question actually
because
um
yes it does but not uh it seems not in
the way we think it's not sort of very
fast changes
and the changes actually happen on the
dermal level
on the more internal level rather than
on the external level so there is lots
of data on that and again I'm sure a lot
more is coming but it's not you know
there are certain transient changes
let's say you travel somewhere you you
know you bought the plane and then you
know after that you feel your skin is
dry and obviously you caught some
bacteria but if your skin is healthy it
will fight this kind of foreign bacteria
and will recover to its sort of natural
uh state